muito boa tarde a todos então é o menor
morre um grande prazer estar aqui no
colégio militar quando foi lançado o
desafio de falar sobre um tema que
passava efetivamente a questão da
educação e sobretudo lideranças do
movimento que é a minha primeira análise
foi olhar um pouco para que o que todos
nós fazemos na nossa vida o que eu fiz é
o que eu faço e tentar perceber qual o
denominador comum um passado neste
momento falar daquilo que eu fiz
entender metragem hoje questões que
funcionam atualmente com o fato está na
televisão o dar aulas com as suas
medidas comuns que eventualmente podem
tocar essas questões que têm a ver com a
liderança mas rapidamente percebi que só
tenhamos claro pra fazer e portanto eu
vou em termos técnicos falar sobre os
live e depois virar aquilo que eu acho
premial fundamental importantes e que
tentará transmitir como fundo no fundo
da minha própria experiência que é o que
pra mim mais importante muitas vezes as
questões de natureza técnica ou seja
existem aqui alguns fatores são sempre
importantes um deus nós possamos
clareamento nos quatro pilares que você
nem sempre essas questões relacionadas
com a herança encostam e conforme como
nós temos um deus é questão da motivação
não faz sentido estão turvas não faz
sentido absolutamente nada
se nós próprios não tivemos motivado
sobretudo as pessoas com quem nós temos
e com quem nós trabalhamos também possam
estar motivado tal motivação intrínseca
e extrínseca que vem pro em primeiro
lugar pelo prazer do que o que estou
fazendo e não vale a pena estar em nada
se não tiver com paixão e compreender e
aceitar uma intervenção desde que pôs
objectivamente não conseguiu fugir isso
muitas vezes até a última instância que
vai do conhecimento social das viagens
com estrangeira tem inclusivamente o
dinheiro que queremos que não na
sociedade em que nós temos é também
acontece
um outro aspecto é que elas estão
querendo que eu tomar a decisão que
talvez o patamar última das competências
que os últimos chamados complexos
ecológicos ou seja dando um exemplo eu
enquanto árbitro que o prêmio era
fundamental é tomar uma decisão
existem fatores contingência uma decisão
tão do ambiente é o time mais ou menos
pessoas gostaram de ver ou fazer sol
tudo isso naturalmente que que implica
alguma coisa na minha decisão é questão
da própria tarefa mas sobretudo alguém
que nós queremos trabalhar em ser porque
não posso ler em cheio as condições
climatéricas que têm a ver sobretudo com
o próprio
em vigor já às competências e aqui é que
os chega a 100 para a conclusão é que o
nível de uma decisão há uma coisa que eu
posso dizer que é minha competência
vamos treinar mais trabalhar mais é
focar mais no que o meu objetivo e
portanto para onde está motivado pelo
projeto que eu faço é questão
fundamental que eu queria desenvolver
mais competências em áreas onde possa
dar respostas não são aquilo que eu
quero
depois finalmente é que o que nós temos
aqui a falar que é a questão da
liderança existem números faz frases e
palavras deixou o time da liderança
para mim o mais importante é a
possibilidade que eu tenho de alguma
maneira em relação às pessoas que me
rodeiam poderem influenciar o desempenho
do seu comportamento mas com um
princípio para mim é fundamental não é
um circo das instituições no que eu
posso estar lá com propostas servidas
instituições e isso pra mim é
fundamental
por isso muita time motivado pois vão
estar motivados melhorar as minhas
competências para que ele não seja mais
importante e relevante e as questões da
influência do comportamento do meu e de
todos aqueles que me veio para me tornar
melhor líder mas tudo isso só faz
sentido na minha perspectiva de uma
maneira que esta palavra que dava no
fundo o tema daquilo que vou falar que a
questão da atitude
todos nós já temos um jogo futebol e
percebemos que é uma equipe que
sistematicamente ganhasse com dois gols
de zé papel em 21 sorte graças ganhar a
segunda bola que não é sorte é postura e
comportamento que é uma equipe que está
naquele momento do jogo estas duas bolas
é uma questão de atitude
e é sobre isso que você entrar os 11
minutos que não só da minha palestra
para descansar e daqui um desafio eu
trouxe aqui três contra este mal ok e
agora é tempo de ele estar em cuba 35
mais 42 igual aos 37 28 mais 31 escolas
3642 mais 15 igual a cinquenta e sete
empresas contexto mar tem aqui alguém
que seja bom em matemática que possa dar
uma ajuda rapidamente o que salta do que
vocês vêem ajuda a embrapa também vim cá
os pôneis ao ponto está o ponto nos
apontar quem está ali ponto obrigado
pelo convite em casa por causa dessas
contas não quis macaé por entender que
assim permite ter lugar em 200 perto
fantástico em 66% as contas certas mas
não foi diferente para quem sabe fazer
aí que tá errada conta e este nosso tema
educação
nós crescemos e aprendemos exatamente
com estudos americano de vela quem cef
deve comparar uma criança pai mãe saiba
dizer que não
não pode o jornalismo não salte não
faças depois vez em quando vem um
feedback positivo mas eu enquanto
árbitro
percebe se claramente porque normalmente
quando acertava o objetivo em mente a
conta certa é aquela que nós aceitamos
ninguém se lembra mas se ligar novamente
ninguém esquece
mas qual a importância de nós colocarmos
o foco na conta certa olhos conta certa
nas contas erradas porque nós
influenciamos o nosso corpo em temos
química química influências a gente sabe
que existem 20 substâncias químicas é
chamado sendo filhos são vocês que nós
chegamos no momento entradas assinados
por exemplo talvez esse físico e esses
testes com mais proteína que é uma coisa
porque não sei se houve falar nesse nome
que é uma substância controlada
possessão os três aceitavam as
enxaquecas efe que se acredita
implementos onu quer dizer que quando eu
estou a apostar em coisas boas positivas
e construtivas sistematicamente os
obrigará a se livrar dessa menina que é
uma substância que vai fazer uma série
de coisas e que influencia não ter
sotaque em resistência o sistema
imunológico fora e o contrário quando
estamos chateados em gados mau humor
existem substâncias químicas no caso do
policial que vamos chegar e vou fazer
exatamente o contrário por isso como uma
coisa normal
normalmente cinco as coisas mal e que
importância das contas certas contas
erradas não pela questão do número baixo
pela questão da atitude
a maneira como eu encaro em qualquer
circunstância em qualquer situação
a conta certa o tal como lhe chama o
brasil que nós queremos realmente olhar
e ver por isso acreditar o objetivo
essencial mas pra mim o fundamental em
fazer diferença objetivamente é atitude
é um jogador que eu tenho com o negócio
pode ver mais pra lá em forma sustentada
com os pés no chão mas a capacidade que
eu tenho de acreditar que posso ir mais
longe
sabem que nós somos português muitas
vezes temos aquela perspectiva é que
dizemos mal de tudo alguém dizia que a
doença mais preocupante em portugal é a
vivência do quarto em um dos pátios
alguém porque a gente está sendo ruim ou
quem vai pagar 4 estou sempre a cachaça
agora está a chover em agora vou
perguntar se queira botar um só e eu
estava muito calor mas é uma coisa que é
muito importante e com os nossos
antepassados nos deixaram que é uma
coisa que peço a você já deve ter ouvido
falar que o novo caminho da ruína sabe
quem vai jogar ainda navegar contra o
vento e este é o grande desafio dos
portugueses há 500 anos atrás fizeram
por quinto aluno no livro peso e começar
novas regras envolvendo frente em manaus
para trás e os com os temas é o
descobriram que quanto mais for possível
através dos seus temas delas conseguiu
fazer nem mais rápido contra o vento e
este é o grande desafio todos nós temos
todos os dias é capacitar olham e
podemos conseguir vialle navegar à
bolina contra os ventos conta as marés
por isso posturas diferentes normalmente
com dos resultados diferentes é aquela
diferença que nós tivemos entre o
pessimista ou otimista
normalmente um pessimista é assim
desgraçado com o macaé o mec não é
momento de se modificar naquela
oportunidade
jogo futebol às nove da manhã a grande
deixa te estar chuva enquanto a china
amanhã porque o que nós olhamos precisou
com uma dificuldade e não fazendo como
pensionista estamos com vc como já
conquistou obrigado
quando eu era mais novo que precisava
dessa biografia que ver novamente uma
oportunidade em grandes dificuldades e
as nove da manhã está xv está lana eu
vou mostrar claramente em uma boa
condição física você com 50 e este é o
grande desafio
nós vemos nessa circunstância nesse
potencial uma oportunidade e não olhar
para aquilo como uma grande chatice uma
grande dificuldade é eu as palavras têm
muita força cada vez mais peças de roupa
e uma das questões que o bloco é o que
nós dizemos sobretudo em relação às
promessas pressa para isso faz a
diferença nós por falar uma palavra
linda como a palavra expressa o que
fizemos duas duas outras palavras trevas
da palavra onde nenhum time mais ou
menos aquele desgraçado que entra todo
roto afinal no final fazer um teste com
o pedrocão e utilizamos outra palavra
que a palavra morte é algo negativo e
escola a importância é importante que eu
faço como sempre faz os comentários na
televisão sobre os seus planos quando o
árbitro erra ninguém me ouviu dizer vou
falar um homem só que o barco onde nunca
digo do artigo 11 do regulamento onde
não está
tomou se manteve uma decisão não foi
correta pois a palavra positiva correto
a fazer aquele gol mas quando eu acerto
um amigo duarte gomes teve uma excelente
decisão eo juízo a palavra o nome de wes
o cio acho esse de pior foi a decisão e
isso faz a diferença nas palavras
até por causa daquela gestão da
substância e portanto eu posso utilizar
a palavra expressa em dizer que a última
a morrer posso falar em cena primária e
vez dizia utilizar a palavra moto o
fizera o que é mais forte a existência
de vida e portanto muitas vezes é um
desafio muito simpático natal e falou já
levamos surgiu de percebemos que o gil e
tom que o vant importante é olharmos
palavras positivas e construtivas
iser também programa mesmo sentido
muitas vezes até pra corrigir alguma
coisa está mal
eu pedi ajuda duas pessoas são minhas
amigas opcional ea inumerável irina por
nós percebemos agora vou fazer aqui um
mundial não consegue imitar o que o
senhor vai falar amanhã mais um diálogo
entre o que foi o mundial 2010 ronaldo e
irina quando eu tenho pois é a partir
daqui deste ao esperado por nós
percebemos exatamente essa função das
perspectivas
o cristiano ronaldo eo azul na vida
assim sim gosto tanto que vou tentar não
tem mais nada mais ou menos cinco
importantes pra por este momento em que
ela respondeu que eles que vai embora e
em mclaren russo naturalmente eu não nem
penso nisso e ela respondeu é mesmo
totalmente as mesmas a quarta pergunta
plantar 60 00 e às vezes em claro muito
e muito e ela respondeu alguma vez um 3
a 1 mas como é que a gente faz lobby não
em grande né o porquê ainda perguntas é
o segundo beijo eu vejo que sempre
possível ela vai bater e eu vejo os dois
não sou desse ano pessoal x posso
confiar em ti e houve sim e ela responde
incríveis pretende agora para não vou
fazer magia
vou colocar isso aqui se não fosse o de
filmes de baixo para cima
ok ela inscreveu sim posso confiar em ti
os dois não sou esse ano só vai bater
sempre possível baixa não porque ainda
pergunta alguma vez 135 ar muito e
muitos anos não nem penso nisso que vai
embora sem que eu tanto esperava por
este momento é exatamente isto
eu não sei nada o fato está lá a chover
as nove da manhã ontem fazer uma coisa
qualquer que seja o difícil falar agora
a perspectiva
vamos olhar de cima para baixo os
olhares para cima
vamos olhar pelo lado positivo o lado
negativo vamos utilizar as palavras
corretas e assertivas
vamos usar aquelas palavras que não
muitas vezes nós usamos ok este é
efectivamente o desafio é uma lição vida
que é que se pode dizer que eu tente
tirar os meus quarenta e nove anos de
idade e espero ter mais alguns pré
continuar a aprender é o seguinte é que
ao longo de minha carreira como árbitro
e acreditem que tive colegas que eram
muito mais talentosos que eu mas muito
mais que efetuem as condições por
exemplo será a vítima
mas os 3.750 jovem deixará uma visão
tanto no processo inclusivo e muitas
vezes nós não conseguimos vencer entre
aspas não temos tanto também com outra
pessoa mas é uma coisa que nós e é um
fator que nós não se efectuar que vem
depois força e quando acabou o treino e
nós vamos mais voltas do treino
e fazendo mais 50 homenagem e quando
vamos voltar a ler cuida do jogo é que o
um treino da seleção no final e toda a
gente comeu e houve uma pessoa que tem
não sei quantos carros não sei quanto
dinheiro tem bastante lembradas como o
que chama de final e fez uma coisa tão
simples quanto isso o que eu mais você
quantas bolas vão ter mais 50 livros 50
anos foi nosso iluminação é bobagem e
que joão pimenta e isso faz toda a
diferença e já está no topo é algo que
eu sabe que constantemente que entendem
que o talento se o messi tem ou não tem
mais talento é que kyoto e que nós temos
que atuar exatamente na questão do
empenho e esforço por isso terminado já
andou sorte
já sobre o de todos vocês nas vossas
vidas pessoais e profissionais muito
sucesso alguém um dia escreveu esta
frase que o sucesso é uma questão de
sorte
você achava que o autor desta frase é
basicamente uma pessoa chamada foi a
danone porque o que eu tenho certeza é
que a senhora é uma conta matemática que
tem dois fatores muito importantes por
um lado acontece e por outro lado a
oportunidade sabem por quê porque em
quanto tempo pode ter três ou quatro
oportunidades nunca vai conseguir ganhar
mas quem tiver competência e trabalhar
pra isso é assim que surge no final da
guerra os outros conforme o estágio não
é para jogar teve muita sorte estava
linda que eu mantenho o foco era a
paixão é competente e com essa contenda
silva ganharam ao precisar que foi nada
e é por isso que só com muita gente
costuma dizer só está muito trabalho e
eram muitas vezes a dificuldade e nós
vivemos um contexto social europeu com
muitas dificuldades com muita gente usa
o prazo que nós temos que receber
engajar bastante itália 31 quilos
consegue se vocês nunca fui atrás do que
nunca vão ter se você não contar a
resposta vai ser sempre não se você não
passar frio segundo lugar e isso é
importante não ter medo de arriscar
como já foi dito que várias pessoas
improvisam temos medo de cá estamos para
o prato o erro mas se ficarmos parados
não sei vamos lá não vamos conseguir
alcançar
não vamos conseguir ter não vamos
conseguir chegar também por isso é que
eu pessoalmente gosto muito do
impossível porque a concorrência é
sempre um enorme desafio para vocês
risco em risco e mesmo processo é esse e
sobretudo para que os outro vídeo
muito obrigado por experientes sejam
felizes porque a sociedade é realmente o
nosso caminho
obrigado